let's get you some breaking news this
hour State media and Somalia say that
the country's security forces are
dealing with the so-called terrorist
incident this has taken place at a hotel
in the port city of kismayu a car Laden
with explosives reportedly rammed into
the gate of the building let's get more
on this we can speak to Gemma Noor Ahmed
he is live from the capital Mogadishu
what more can you tell us
exchange of fire this is still happening
between the government the security
forces and the attackers in that hotel
and the sources of jubalan
administration is telling that for a
number of al-shabab groups are inside
the hotel and they are exchanging a fire
with the with the security forces
the sum of sources told me that a number
of people were injured in this attack
some of them were three students who
were in past a school bus was crossing
the road while the explosion happened
this hotel which is has been attacked is
residing number of
jubalan officials and elders and the uh
al-shabab group is told that they have
launched this attack on this hotel but
they didn't give any details about a
number of their groups who are at
attacking that place or they didn't tell
any uh Our Father details about what is
going on inside but the the what way I
can assure you at this moment is that
the fighting is going on in this hotel
and the security forces are surrounding
it and they are trying to rescue the
resonances of this hotel and it is very
hard at this time to to know how many
how many people who are injured or
killed in this attack actually
okay thank you for that update Noor
Ahmed speaking to us there from
somalia's Capital Mogadishu about this
uh breaking news that we're getting an
ongoing incident uh deal which is being
described as a terrorist incident at a
hotel in the port city of kismayu